Hello YouTube subscribers
Right now, our relationship is a bit, complicated.
While it feels like just the two of us, me
making videos for you, there's really three
of us.
And for you to be able to watch one of my
videos, three things need to happen:
1.
I make the video.
2.
I have to put it somewhere.
That's YouTube for a variety of reasons.
3.
You need to be told that the video is up.
The internet is a big place and it's easy
to miss stuff.
This last part is, presumably, why you're
a subscriber and why, hopefully, you're seeing
this video.
But I hear from a lot of people that the message
about a new video being up doesn't always
get though.
Now I don't want to point any fingers or anything,
*but that's totally on YouTube*.
For whatever reason, they've had a bit of
a history when it comes to *not* always sending
notifications to subscribers.
Like my last video which went up in the middle
of some huge technical problem with subscriber
feeds.
This kind of thing has been going on for years.
Also, YouTube has been going the FaceBook
path of deciding for you what you want to
watch, instead of just showing you the stuff
you subbed to.
So they might just ignore what you've subscribed
to for their own business reasons which turns
the subscriber button into more of a suggestion
from you rather than a request.
And, because I don't have a way to talk to
you directly, YouTube can, at any time, for
any reason, basically just shut down a channel.
Just done.
That's a lot of power that I hope they'd never
lean on in a negotiations with creators.
But anyway:
I've been thinking about this a lot and I've
figured out a crazy technological solution
to all of the above: it's called email.
Yeah, seriously.
I know email feels like barely post-industrial
technology at this stage, but I've been testing
it out with several tens of thousands of people
and it's working great.
If you want to always see the things I've
made, click this button, enter your address,
and I can just tell you when I've made things.
It's amazing.
And we don't have to rely on YouTube to pass
notes for us.
It makes our relationship direct and clear.
And I've spent a lot of time figuring out
how to make it work best for you.
Click here to try it out.
...
Still here huh.
Not sure quite why...
Guess I should say something...
Well, I've been thinking about the relationship
between creators and audiences for a while
now.
I've written about it here, and spoken with
Brady, my podcast co-host about it here and
here.
If you're interested, you can click and check
those things out as well.
Still watching, huh?
Well this is getting weird, so I'm going to
just end the video now.
Bye...
Seriously.